on passe maintenant à notre second débat
vous le savez débat de société
volontairement décalée de l'actualité
connaissez-vous la fast fashion la mode
jetable et les plus en plus critique et
on va évaluer la réalité du virage
écologique pris par l'industrie de la
mode pour commencer vous propose ce
reportage avec for life c'est une marque
de vêtements pour hommes que société
créée en 2018 qui ne produit que le
strict nécessaire en précommande flora
sauvage
chaque année en europe 4 millions de
tonnes de vêtements sont jetés seuls 20
% sont recyclés un gaspillage qui ne
concerne pas que les consommateurs mais
aussi les marques de mode rapide pour
que les prix restent abordables
elles produisent en masse dans ce grand
magasin la prise de conscience est
récente un étage entier dédié à la vente
de vêtements de seconde main vient
d'ouvrir au public je pense que toute la
crise qu vide à être un révélateur et un
détonateur énorme on s'est rendu compte
qu'on portait pas donc on a revendu
trier mis de côté ou pour nous c'est
aussi moment adéquat pour prendre la
parole et puis d'ici 2030 la deuxième
main représentera le double de toutes
les enseignes de mode accessible elle
aussi un véritable enjeu en termes de
business à aller capter certaines
marques n'ont pas attendu pour lutter
contre la surconsommation for life a
choisi de s'affranchir des stocks et des
invendus dans cette boutique parisienne
on peut essayer son vêtement récupérer
sa commande mais on repart les mains
vides c'est une marque est basé sur la
pré commande donc qui ne fait aucun sur
stock donc on ne fabrique que à demande
on met en vente un produit pendant un
mois donc
un projet sur lequel on a travaillé
pendant peut-être un an donc une chemise
un blouson en cuir un pantalon on pense
à tous les détails on met en vente
pendant un mois les gens commandent ce
produit est ensuite on lance la
production et les clients sont au rendez
vous simon commande régulièrement chez
for life par conscience environnementale
bonjour si on a la chemise ralph donc en
coton bio un peu épais l'essai de ne
plus aller dans des boutiques on va dire
des grandes boutiques et je privilégie
kmd boutique avec une certaine démarche
derrière ses produits en europe donc il
ya aussi ça qui compte et enfin la
démarche d'air écologique finis les
achats impulsifs le contre-pied de for
life séduit de plus en plus d'hommes la
jeune marque s'inscrit dans une démarche
globale éco-responsable et affiche 100 %
de croissance tous les ans
que pèse la mode éthique et responsable
que valent les promesses des grandes
marques l'industrie du vêtement est elle
vraiment en train de faire sa révolution
voilà quelques unes des questions que
l'on va aborder tout de suite avec mes
invités catherine d'aurillac bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes présidente de la
fashion révolution de france rédactrice
en chef adjointe de la revue de mode u
magdi mode responsable du maïs riz par
la mode responsable et engagée c'est là
dessus vous positionnez valley retreat
bonsoir bienvenue créatrice du podcast
chiffon autrice de la base a été publié
aux éditions du cherche midi benjamin
sim et lower bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi professeur à l'institut français
de la mode et puis avec nous en
visioconférence audrey millet qui est
historienne bonsoir vos publié le livre
noir de la mode création production
manipulation c'est aux éditions les
pérégrine peut-être une définition je
parlais de de fast fashion sais c'est
quoi catherine d'aurillac la fast
fashion à la fast fashion c'est la mode
jetable qui existe depuis la fin des
années 90 on va dire 95 98 qui a
remplacé le made in france qu'on
connaissait à l'époque et qui c'est bon
le marché s'est emballé en fait et
la fast fashion a complètement envahi
nos placards avec quoi avec eux parce
que moi j'étais habitué basiquement je
sais pas avoir deux de collection awards
deux collections par saison de castle
mais qu'en fait il ya combien de
collection maintenant ça ces rebelles
effectivement il peut y avoir jusqu'à
cinquante deux
semaines on sort on sort de la direction
ça c'est des capsules et des réassorts
de couleurs des réassorts de forme mais
et voilà c'est voilà c'est la course à
l'échalote la course à la consommation
vitrine qu'est ce que vous en pensez je
pas tout à fait d'accord effectivement
la fast fashion c'est consommer gîte
mais maintenant on est arrivé à un
tel point qu'il y a plusieurs face à
sean healy a effectivement des
aberrations comme on peut citer des
marques ou pas comme je la lis exprès
tout ce qui se passe en chine en ce
moment qu'il a encourage ces mêmes
populations consommation ces deux là
c'est il encourage les ados à consommer
des vêtements au moins dix euros face et
c'est vraiment mon beauf du vêtement et
à côté vous avez quand même les anciens
la fast fashion h&m zara groupe inditex
qui pour moi maintenant font un effort
et ne sont pas du tout dans cette
surproduction et quand on parle de
collection sinon man en revanche pas
d'accord et non mais h&m je suis allé
dans leurs locaux j'ai vu comment ça se
passait ils ont vraiment un véritable
engagement pour pour protéger aussi les
ouvriers enfin il ya de bien tout parce
que pour moi la fast fashion c'est sa
touche plusieurs ya un problème
économique un point une politique et un
problème sociétal il ya tout ça à la
fois donc on a tendance à tout à tirer à
boulet de canon sur la fête s'achève
dans un champ de la fast fashion c'est
pas bien sans savoir ce qui a vraiment
derrière notamment les emplois qui avait
d'ailleurs c'est ce que les ajustements
h et j'ai peut-être pas été très clair
mais par exemple voient le cada chaîne
ce que j'ai fait un reportage chez eux
il ya deux ou trois ans hm ils ont
vraiment par exemple dans les innovants
de la dèche ils ont des entreprises les
salariés ont plus vraiment comment
diriger un salaire minimal et ont des
syndicats
le salaire minimum ni minium minimum
existe dans tous les pays mais le
salaire minimum n'est pas un salaire
vital salaire minimum c'est un tiers du
salaire vital ne l'oublions pas oui donc
les avantages de la fast fashion excusez
moi je vais juste pour la parole en tant
que citoyenne c'est que c'est beaucoup
moins cher pour tout même seulement dire
que on peut avoir des pièces parce qu'on
sait que zara h&m mango copient les
grands créateurs et donc on peut avoir
des pièces moins cher devrait passer
quand même la problématique comment
éthiquement
promouvoir une mode qui copie à moindre
prix avec les dégâts environnementaux
apprend l'arrivée de la fast fashion en
avant
la consommation c'est d'abord de la mode
en fait c'est de la mode rapide et la
mort le pratiquer le principe de la mode
troisième de la mode c'est qu'on
s'habille pas pour satisfaire un besoin
de protéger du froid ou
néon sami éventuellement pour des
raisons esthétiques ou pour donner un
message et il ya ce principe de
renouvellement perpétuel
du vestiaire des collections des dons ce
qu'on appelle des styles ou des
tendances et la fascination extremis a
en fait oui si on est à cinquante deux
collections par an est aimanté parfois
plus effectivement
plusieurs milliers de références
nouvelles fils ou des semaines tout
n'a pas encore entendu audrey
je vous donne la parole peut être sur
une dimension un peu
géographique et économique quand on dit
fast fashion mois spontanément je vais
penser asie est-ce que c'est forcément
ça se passe forcément en asie non la
fast fashion en fait c'est tout le globe
en fait c'est vraiment un symptôme de la
globalisation ensuite je revient
également sur ce qui vient d'être dit il
y a des hiérarchies dans la mode et il y
a de la fast fashion de l' ultra fashion
du luxe et même des xviiie siècle du
semi luxe il est important de dire que
lorsque les vêtements sont devenues un
peu moins cher à partir du 19ème siècle
on a pu s'habiller en se faisant plus
plaisir à voir plus de choses et c'est
tant mieux c'est tant mieux le problème
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est que il ya
tellement de volume
on utilise tellement
l'agriculture les pesticides on à divers
types de pollution une pollution qui
environnementale bien entendu une
pollution qui est humaine qui relève des
coûts humains et une pollution qui est
également culturel parce que ça fait
cent cinquante ans que la civilisation
industrielle en réalité srp à
l'énergie des combustibles fossiles aux
excès des produits phytosanitaires des
plagiaires de créateurs et ça c'est très
important parce que l'ultra et la fast
fashion c'est ça et aujourd'hui on nous
présente un peu l'addition et la mode on
l'aiment on aimerait bien qu'elle change
et il ya bien entendu des efforts qui
sont en train d'être chez on va parler
justement de des critiques en termes de
pollution avec ce ce quelques chiffres
sur l'industrie du jeans pour commencer
soixante treize pièces vendues par
seconde dans le monde onze mille litres
d'eau moi ça me fait toujours ça me
surprend toujours ces chiffres-là onze
mille litres d'eau nécessaire à la
fabrication d'un seul jean je sais pas
comment on commence ainsi coûte rien et
je vous donnais la branche apprennent 65
mille kilomètres parcourus pour que ce
jean arrive en france onze mille
trop pour un jean commence alors un jean
en coton le coton est très loin de
beaucoup d'eau pour pousser
effectivement mais il faut pondérer
parce que ça dépend des pays à des pays
qui ont pas besoin d un d'irrigation
néanmoins besoin donc pour ça c'est le
chiffre extrêmement va dire c'est un
swing et il faut pondérer
on peut aussi avoir des jeans en lin par
exemple le nymphée une plante qui pousse
ici localement dans nos mairies et
à quel prix c'est l'année du problème
c'est exactement mais au même prix qu'un
jeans levi's aux cantines massy oui mais
le sait le noeud du problème à moi moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour vous
que la copie wee cc à bannir mais
comment vous proposer à un public qui
s'est habitué effectivement avoir des
pièces qui sont dans un souci esthétique
bien sûr abordable comment vous pouvez
changer de modèle est proposé de pardon
ça mais c'est vrai c'est vrai pour la
môme c'est vrai pour bien que beaucoup
de secteurs économiques sont france
transfo confronté aujourd'hui à ces
enjeux de transition environnementale
des noeuds ça passe par des changements
de comportement et ses changements de
comportement des consommateurs sont
quand même en train petit à petit de
faire changer ces secteurs économiques
oui parce qu'on les informe ils sont de
plus en plus influents sont informés
alors effectivement tout le monde ne
peut pas se permettre d'acheter de la
mode éco responsable je suis d'accord
avec vous mais c'est quand même un
mouvement qui est en train de de ceux de
se créer sous nos yeux est ce que vous
êtes d'accord est à l'heure qu'il est je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses je pense
que l'on voit que ce qu'on appelle le
marché de la mode éco responsable mais
je pense que le terme est parfois assez
des voiliers cercle une marque veut dire
qu'elle est coresponsable généralement
elle l'est c'est idriss et voilà c'est
un effet un user de positionnement et de
postures qui souvent alors un peu
donc on voit que c'est trés disent qu'il
est très difficile en fait c'est de
passer à grande échelle c'est à dire que
les marques et qui se positionne la
manière sincère et crédible
on a vu dans le reportage sur des jeunes
sur des sur des modes de production de
distribution et de communication qui
sont plus responsables et plus
acceptable on voit qu'elles ont du mal à
effectivement remplacé les géants c'est
à dire ils ont du mal en fait à
reproduire à grande échelle ce qu'elle
arrive à faire à petite échelle
notamment parce que ça fait pas de la
production locale - mécanisée etc il ya
un deuxième sujet qui est la question de
la consommation de mode et notamment de
mode plus responsable et là et quand
même une alternative aujourd'hui qui est
la seconde
le fait que de plus en plus voilé fait
que de plus en plus de gens et puis
qu'on cherche effectivement des
alternatives en termes de prix on peut
acheter des vêtements qui ont déjà été
portés les vêtements ce concert fera
pendant des siècles mais il se conserve
quand même ils sont plus en plus robuste
et solide et donc ses concerts montant
alors quelques chiffres pour illustrer
cette thématique de la seconde main je
suis sûr que philippe à me suivre en
régie de deux éléments sur le gaspillage
du textile et ensuite sur le marché de
la seconde main sur le gaspillage du
textile 4 millions de tonnes de textiles
jetés chaque année en europe alors ça
c'est sur le saas est sur la seconde je
vous donne la seconde main un milliard
cent de chiffre d'affaires de
transactions par seconde et si je
voulais vous donner les chiffres sur le
gaspillage on l'a on va l'avoir merci de
le présenter à l'antenne 4 millions de
tonnes de textiles jetés chaque année en
europe 3 2 kg de textiles et chaussures
recyclés par français et par en scellier
est évidemment il ya il ya une loi anti
gaspi ya un code réglementaire qui est
contraignant ça change quoi pour les
marques de mode benjamin six men were
bas c'est effectivement ça peut
contraindre un peu leur mode de
production mais j'ai l'impression que
honnêtement le cadre légal qu'il veut
les contraindre un peu n'a pas de des
faits
profond sur le marché de la mode je
pense que les effets ils changent en
interne dans le management des
entreprises ou d'autres valeurs
finalement progresse pas forcément dans
toutes les entreprises et pas forcément
à la vitesse attendu et il vient aussi
du changement de mentalité date il fut
des deux critères de choix des
consommateurs je pense que le
législateur en la matière bon il peut se
mêler des placards mais enfin est assez
rapidement on peut toujours contourner
des règles alors je pense que si je vous
reviendrai pas être très loin il va
pouvoir nous nous nous rejoindre pour
lui laisser le temps d'arriver je vais
proposer à bastille venez venez parce
que je voulais que vous me disiez soin
de loi et hugo et voilà ce que le
gouvernement y cursi d'arrivée c'est
qu'on parle de loi parce que le
gouvernement voilà fait et prépare en la
matière le gouvernement s'engage il
s'engage en faveur de l'économie
circulaire alors première question
thomas qu'est ce que l'économie
circulaire qu'est ce que cache ce nom un
peu techno il faut lire l'économie
circulaire c'est comme son nom l indique
une économie qui fonctionne en boucle
c'est une rupture au moins sur le papier
avec l'économie actuelle une économie
qu'on qualifie de linéaire qui consiste
à utiliser les matières premières pour
les transformer les consommer et puis et
puis plus rien et puis séduira construit
mais jeter sa saison 2011 jettent les
produits dans la poubelle l'économie
circulaire elle va redéfinir notre
modèle de consommation il s'agit de
réduire au minimum les déchets en
favorisant la réutilisation la remise à
neuf et le recyclage c'est un cercle en
principe vertuelle au gouvernement a
souhaité en faire la promotion avec
notamment une annonce phare fait par
edouard philippe lui même écouter
c'était en 2000 et 19 edouard philippe
qui présente le dispositif anti
gaspillage du gouvernement écoutez le
nous aurons l'occasion de prendre une
mesure qui consistera en l'interdiction
de l'élimination les uns aujourd'hui les
avants d'une offre les invendus en
général ce sera une première mondiale et
notre idée encore une fois ça n'est pas
de contrat ou d'imposer c'est de faire
en sorte d'accompagner les entreprises
dans la gestion de leur temps de leur
production dans le recyclage de leurs
produits bref faire en sorte que nous
passions à tenir la nouvelle de
fonctionnement économique pour
économiser les matières et éviter ce
gaspillage à supporter alors
concrètement ça fonctionne ou ça va
fonctionner comment ce dispositif entré
en vigueur janvier 2022 20 c dans deux
mois le dispositif vient donc de la loi
anti gaspillage adoptée par le parlement
en février 2020 il prévoit une
obligation d'information sur les
caractéristiques environnementales des
produits il instaure aussi une
interdiction de la destruction des
produits invendus c'est la mesure phare
du dispositif
il prévoit enfin un renforcement de la
responsabilité
les producteurs voilà pour le dispositif
adopté voté par le parlement je vous
propose d'écouter brune poirson vous
savez c'est l'ancien secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de la transition
écologique souvenez-vous bruine pense
poirson avait porté ce projet de loi
elle avait d'ailleurs été présentée
baptisé ministre française de la mode
par le new york times à l'époque fait un
bruit réducteur mais bon brune poisson
précisément défendez le dispositif du
gouvernement lors du sommet tianjin la
hausse était au début de l'année 2020 au
grand palais à paris écouter en anglais
s'il vous plaît ls fifty million years
of claude haridge ce disque harding
hinault t-shirt thannoise maintenant sa
noce
dincer louer
des skis scénario et is born to create
ndjili in france non hélas going to be
for better et pour terminer thomas
pression que les grandes marques se sont
engagés auprès d'emmanuel macron c'était
lors du g7 organisé à biarritz à l'été
2010 9 30 acteurs du secteur de la mode
s'est engagé pour des objectifs dit éco
responsable c'est ce qu'on a appelé le
pacte de la mode le fashion pacte ans en
bon français en engagements non
contraignants mais qu emmanuel macron
avait alors présenté comme la première
coalition d'envergure en faveur d'une
mode éthique merci steve pour ces
précisions au drame y est ce ce fashion
pas que ce pacte de la mode est ce qu il
a été suivi de quelques-uns forestière
certains dévoila des grands des grandes
ce secteur économique qui avait pris les
devants
techniquement
françois henri pinault a réussi à amener
quand même plusieurs entreprises ensuite
il est pas contraignant ils les cibles
véritablement l'environnement et moi ce
qui m'inquiète plus c'est
l'environnement ça y est on commence à
secouer il ya eu le giec est là qu au 26
mai c'est le les facteurs sociaux en
fait qu'ils sont très problématiques
c'est à dire que quand des enfants en
inde boivent de l'eau de leur village et
ont besoin d'une greffe de rein à trois
ans lorsqu'on se rend compte qu'il ya
des produits toxiques tels du mercure du
cadmium du baryum dans par exemple les
sous vêtements noirs et que ça favorise
l'infertilité chez nous également là on
se demande s'il faut pas intervenir au
niveau de la santé publique bien entendu
on a aussi un autre problème donc là je
sais un problème de santé publique mais
aussi un problème de consommation alors
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut on arrête
pas de consommer de toute façon on n'a
pas le droit de sortir tout nu on a des
vêtements dans notre placard et on a
aussi le droit de se faire plaisir et
faire un peu pour ça la vie en mai la
consommation est quand même devenu
l'idole d'une époque ensuite on a
différents types de consommateurs c'est
à dire qu'il y en a qui achètent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup très très peu
cher puis en étions pas le choix et
qu'ils achètent peu donc là c'est un
problème économique cela signifie que
les salaires aussi ils ne sont pas assez
élevés et qu'on est obligé d'acheter
moins cher c'est pas très bon signe sans
au fait on a bien entendu toutes ces
questions
ça s'ouvre un petit peu actuellement
mais de déni des faits scientifiques et
cela me paraît extrêmement graves de
toujours remettre le sujet dans des
controverses active qui en fait fabrique
du doute et parce que ce serait
potentiellement le secteur de la mode et
pas celui de l'agro alimentaire ou du
tabac ou de l'environnement c'est
glamour ça des paillettes on n'aurait
pas le droit de l'examiner en fait c'est
un c'est un des secteurs les plus
importants au monde est extrêmement
intéressant il touche à beaucoup
beaucoup à l'économie à la littérature à
l'esthétique bien entendu au social aux
emplois et je pense qu'ils me les très
importants même pour aider les autres
secteurs d'examiner profondément le
secteur de l'habillement valérie tribune
et même moi j'ai envie de dire il est
particulièrement examiné le secteur de
la mode cc des marques qui sont par leur
notoriété
surexposée peut être particulièrement
surveillé aussi est ce que vous diriez
sa
survie alors on est aussi par les
associations
bien évidemment mais là c'est mais c'est
ce qui me dérange un peu c'est justement
ce que c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure en parlaient de greenwashing et
ce à cet effet de mode me dérange il ya
des tendances comme ça il ya cinq ans
c'était la mode féministe j'ai jamais su
ce que c'était après on a commencé à
nous parler de la mode jean genre et
maintenant on nous parle de la mode
inclusive tout ça vous avez l'impression
qu'on passe un
enjeu d'éco responsabilité soit soit
notion de mode cc s'est
mal exprimé mais pour moi il ya beaucoup
de marques qui se sont faites en comment
dirais-je en utilisant un discours
marqué t on en voit là nous sommes made
in france made in paris fabriqué avec
amour
alors qu'on sait très bien que la
plupart des fringues ont été faits aux
parties ont été fabriqués au portugal ou
en pologne enfin tout ça pour moi c'est
en fait 50 minutes c'est trop coût 45
c'est trop court pour débat sur ce sujet
parce que c'était déjà bien c'est énorme
et ça donne beaucoup de sites beaucoup
beaucoup de ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure beaucoup de domaines aussi bien
politique qu'économique sociale en
aborde certains il ya mais il ya même
une notion benjamin 6 mai n'avoir que
vous êtes prof de philo je crois c
c'est intéressant la place du vêtement
de rue et justement une société dans
justement j'allais rebondir la suisse
tire que en fait moi j'ai l'impression
que la mode est quand même
particulièrement mises en question en
fait mme merkel est pas je pense pas
qu'elle soit moins discuté dans l'espace
public que que l'automobile
l'alimentation ou d'autres voilà taux de
marché très important et en fait je
pense qu'une des raisons pour ça c'est
que la mode c'est pas seulement des
vêtements c'est aussi un discours à
propos de l'époque est historiquement on
voit que la mode à cette place dans la
société parce que le vêtement est tout
ce qu il engage à être une forme de
langage ou en tout cas un système de
communication très fort et qui permet
aux individus bas d'affirmer des choses
sans avoir besoin de parler et du coup
la mode concret la mode qu'on voit sur
les défilés la mode qu'on voit sur
internet partout etc on lui assigne la
mission de représenter la société et
donc ça veut dire que la mode ne peut
pas passer c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à doter la mutation de nos
sociétés pour lui reproduire de défense
du climat de la biodiversité enfin voila
on lui reproche historiquement d'avoir
un coup de retard c'est à dire d'être
restée sur des sujets aussi importants
effectivement que la diversité l'éco
responsabilité et une série d'autres
causes sociétales majeures on lui
reproche finalement d'être restèrent un
modèle assez archaïque quoi c'est à dire
préférant effectivement la production de
masse la reproduction de stéréotypes de
beauté qui sont pour le moment quand
même assez éculés on lui a reproché
beaucoup ça il semble quand on regarde
quand même effectivement les discussions
qui se trament part au sein de ce milieu
là que un certain nombre de ses sujets
et enfin trouvé une chambre d'écho donc
c'est pas seulement du greenwashing y en
a mais c'est pas ça peut être un
argument comme et je vous le disais on
n'est pas dupe de ces marquise étiquette
seul éco responsable
le problème le procès n'est pas très bon
catherine 5 c'est que casey d'aurillac
pardon or ce conseil n'est pas encore
suffisamment c'est que les labels on s'y
perd un peu il y en a heureusement qu'il
y en a mais c'est pas si facile de s'y
retrouver moi j'aimerais quand même où
il est la belle sait c'est un c'est un
souci bien sur mon île à dire la belle
qui sont très connus et alors si vous
deviez en citer un exemple label max
havelaar je vais le site et parce que
c'est un label de commerce équitable
donc on le connaît pour l'agriculture et
pour l'alimentation pour la banane
chocolat le café médical de sortir un
standard coton dont qui certifie un
coton et équitable c'est-à-dire pas
forcément bio mais cultiver dans de
bonnes conditions avec des améliorations
coopérative et qui participe donc de la
gouvernance de leur coopérative alors
sinon après y'a écotaxe god tout çà çà
çà çà certifie des choses qui sont déjà
dans les lois européennes
c'est à dire la non toxicité des
produits employés pour les teintures etc
etc moi je voudrais revenir quand même
source qui a été dit précédemment
parce que aujourd'hui on est dans une
société une économie qui demande la
décarbonisation est en fait je me
rendrai on se rend compte à jeudi je
excusez moi parce que je suis à fond
dans les dossiers on se rend compte
qu'en fait la mode aujourd'hui c'est 65
% de plastique et de pétrole c'est à
dire que la production de tissus
mondiaux c'est 65 à 70% de polyester ce
pelé est infini dans les lan fils ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure donc ces
décharges à ciel ouvert au ghana en
afrique maintenant au chili on en
découvre tous les jours alors on a envie
de dire stop à quoi ça sert de fabriquer
des vêtements en plastique pour les
jeter cinq minutes après voilà c'est
juste une question non mais c'est une
question et une et une opinion vous
parliez de aussi de l'impact presque
politique de du vêtement et de la mode
laetitia on savait vous êtes amusé à
chercher ce que ça pouvait signifier
pour certaines personnalités politiques
mais l'habit est politique c'est l'habit
quand un maire se déplace un président
une première dame la seule la première
chose dont on parle dès le départ c'est
comment habiller donc ça les hommes
politiques l'ont intégré ils ont des
personnes autour d'eux qui les conseille
évidemment ce n'est pas du tout
superficiel parce que c'est fondamental
et donc comme c'est une arme politique
certains s'en servent alors bien sûr
dans un concours d'élégance mais bas que
parce que souvent on est quand même plus
c'est lucie temps on semble être
populaire vous voyez il ya toujours ce
pas être trop bien amusé il vaut mieux
voilà il vaut mieux être
et quand même quelques histoires de
costumes qui ont coûté cher à certains
la disaient oui on sait que les costumes
de françois fillon c'était la dernière
grosse affaire avec le pénélope gates
qui l a plombé sa à sa candidature est
vital mais est ce qu'on peut faire
passer aussi un message politique en
matière auront parlé de seconde main on
parlait de voile sur sur notre à travers
ses choix jean luc mélenchon c'est des
messages par exemple que politique il a
une vesse d'ouvriers ont passé clair il
met des cols mao il a des vestes
d'ouvriers donc son message et
politiques et angela merkel par exemple
est la première enfin une des premières
parce que certainement qu'elle a fait
des émules à mettre ses tailleurs
plusieurs fois voilà elle assumait de
mettre ses vêtements plusieurs fois et
pas deux thomas on à dire que tous les
allemands voyait que c'était d'ailleurs
qu'elle avait mis remy est remis et
quand un journaliste lui a fait
remarquer elle a dit moi ma mission
c'est d'être là pour protéger le peuple
allemand et servir le peuple allemand et
pas pour faire un défilé de mode donc
c'était assumé et ensuite on a vu que
par exemple letizia d'espagne qui est
première dame avec la première dame elle
aussi promeut cette seconde main et
surtout aussi le de remettre de porter
plusieurs policiers oui il y à aussi
kate middleton et comme c'était vraiment
l'égérie façon les réseaux sociaux c'est
une star énormément d'adolescents s'y
réfèrent et en fait c'est viviane
westwood qui lui a glissé quand même
plusieurs fois dans l'oreille de
remettre des vêtements et elle a fini
par céder donc vous voyez même quand on
est effectivement
vraiment tout en haut de la pyramide on
peut aussi donner l'exemple
justement c'est à dire que quand on est
en haut de la pyramide d'une certaine
manière on peut jouer avec les codes
vestimentaires de son milieu quand on
est en bas c'est plus compliqué et qui
met des costumes dans la société
aujourd'hui est ce que ce sont vraiment
les gens très argentés très puissant pas
forcément ça peut être effectivement les
chauffeurs de l'été c'est qu'ils ont
besoin de l'uniforme et donc la pression
a changé de tenues régulièrement elle
touche en fait peut-être aujourd'hui
plus les classes populaires encore que
les gens aient les moyens alors vous
vous citiez une créatrice britannique
on voit là une autre c'est stella
mccartney elle était à la coop 26 à
glasgow avec des mots très forts sur
notre terre
je pense qu'il y encore beaucoup de
greenwashing malheureusement je pense
que beaucoup de marques s'en moque tout
simplement mais je pense qu'en ce moment
tout le monde est uni dans l'industrie
de la mode et que nous perdons très
rapidement de notre importance parce que
vous savez les générations x y et z
refusent d'acheter la mauvaise mode la
mode salle ils ne veulent tout
simplement pas en faire partie
que cela vous plaise ou non c'est ça
l'avenir de la mode
elle est puissante cette phrase comme
les nouvelles générations refusent
d'acheter la mode salle valérie trine
c'est non mais je sais rien je suis pas
l'avocate non
c'est intéressant je suis la première à
dire que j'avais podcast vous dialoguez
beaucoup avec des avec des achats ou des
acheteuses et justement sac oui je
voulais dire c'est que je discute aussi
bien avec des acheteuses des acheteurs
des acheteuses mais aussi des créateurs
et et
il ya deux préoccupations différentes
les acheteurs et les acheteurs c'est
souvent le pouvoir d'achat c'était la mc
cartney on adore mais là le moindre la
moindre paire de chaussures
effectivement qui est en cuir vegan ou
qui sait même pas du cube ce que c'est
megan ses 400 500 go qui peut se
permettre d'acheter ça ça j'essaye
j'écoute tout le monde c'est pour ça que
j'ai d'ailleurs pas bill isation on
essaie on essaye de culpabiliser le
consommateur est malheureusement je
pense qu on ne culpabilise pas les
bonnes personnes et l'autre chose c'est
que j'interviewe aussi des créateurs et
qu'est ce que j'entends de la part de
ses créateurs que c'est très difficile
de créer du de faire du made in france
je discutais encore hier avec une
créatrice de chemise qu'ils faisaient du
made in france avant mais là je fais
remarquer que le prix c'est schmid a
vachement bcl me dis mais pas ce que
j'ai et obligea je les vendais pas donc
maintenant je les fais produire en
tunisie voilà donc il ya aussi un
problème de ce côté là et je connais des
manufactures des bonneterie notamment en
bretagne qui elles aussi sont en train
de ramer parce que ça coûte très cher
donc obligé donc comme produire coûte
cher donc leurs vêtements coûtent cher
et les gens n'achètent pas c'est ça et
c'est tout j'ai l'impression qu'on est
dans un système qui se mord la queue
c'est très difficile mais catherine
d'aurillac moi je travaille aussi sur
une chaîne économique bis part pour ne
pas la nommer où je reçois beaucoup de
notamment de jeunes chefs d'entreprises
dirigeants et dirigeantes et des
créateurs de mode moi j'ai l'impression
que toutes les nouvelles marques qui se
créent ces démarches éco-responsables
éthique enfin c'est vraiment c'est qu'au
delà c'est il y en a pas une qui va pas
se créer avec ce modèle il y en a
beaucoup mais alors attention parce que
on est quand même européen quand on dit
made in france made in france c'est ça
peut être médine portugal ça sera de nos
si belles qualités un coup un peu
moindre ces points quand on dit made in
tunisie ça c'est le bassin méditerranéen
c'est vraiment une proximité de
fabrication pour pas jeter la pierre
voilà c'est mieux que d'aller fabriqués
en asie mais alors d'un autre côté il
faut pas oublier non plus que en asie
ils ont besoin de nos commandes pour
vivre exactement mais je vous lasser un
souci dimensions
se tient tous les ans pense pensons
salaire vital c'est à dire au lieu de
payer l'ouvrier 0 18 centimes pour un
t-shirt doublons sont le prix achetons
mois mais doublons être peut-être ça
aussi c c'est une façon de dire le
vêtement le plus écologique est déjà
dans notre placard on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir 15 jean en a pas besoin d'avoir
15 tee-shirt noir ou je ne sais pas
combien de pulls et de doudounes soyons
plus un brin audrey 1000 cc c'est
intéressant ce que vient de dire
catherine drake parce que c'est la
question de la relocalisation c'est un
bouquet vraiment employés notamment par
les politiques surtout les surtout les
thématiques économiques et on peut aussi
l'appliquer à notre débat autour de la
de la mode sauf que ça a des
conséquences qui sont pas seulement
franco-française quoi
oui en fait je crois qu'il faut pas être
binaire faut pas dire noir blanc oui
nous la seconde main pourquoi pas ça
dépend la manière dont on l'achète ça
dépend ce qu'on achète le made in france
pourquoi pas
évidemment travailler avec nos amis
européens à nos amis autour de la
méditerranée et avec l'asie en plus on
est allé polluer donc je pense quand
même on peut faire un effort tout de
même il ya des savoir faire
extraordinaire mais techniquement il
faut vraiment prendre toutes les
solutions
une seule ne suffira pas mais le
problème est économique
c'est à dire que si on veut acheter moi
on va produire moi mieux il faut que les
gens puissent le payer et cette question
du salaire elle va pour l'asie sur le
mât mais elle va aussi pour la france
elle va pour le portugais elle va pour
l'espagnol et bien sûr nos amis italiens
on l'a entendu on l'a dit plusieurs fois
mais mais quand vous dites bon ben il
faut aussi penser à ceux qui travaillent
qui produisent en asie et à faire en
sorte qu'il ya un salaire décent on
entend cet argument mais il ya quand
même une image que je voudrais vous
montrer qu'on connaît tous
audrey millet c'est cette catastrophe
qui a peut être déclencher la prise de
conscience des consommateurs et de
l'industrie de la mode 24 avril 2013
voilà les images c'est au bangladesh
l'effondrement du rhin à plaza c'est à
dacca 1135 ouvriers qui meurt dans cet
accident dans les gravats c'est ça qui
avait frappé dans les gravats on voit
des vêtements qui sont ces blés des plus
grandes marques et ce ne sont pas des
contrefaçons qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé
depuis au de rémy est ce que ça a
fondamentalement changé
alors fondamentalement non ensuite il ya
évidemment maintenant une loi sur la
responsabilité mais moi quand lors leur
anna plaza c'est catastrophique
il ya vraiment eu énormément de morts
ça a été très difficile pour les
indemnisations aussi c'est une histoire
qui est assez terrible mais il ya moins
de morts tous les jours mais c'est tous
les jours c'est marrakech si un sous sol
qui est inondée où il y avait les femmes
qui étaient en train de coudre les
hommes étaient au rez de chaussée c'est
tous les jours donc à un moment il faut
se demander si on veut être habillé avec
une marée noire parce que c'est du
pétrole déjà un dressing marée noire
c'est pas très classe il faut se
demander si on va être habillée avec les
fruits d'esclavagé sion de ça pour nos
enfants dans quel monde où le veut ou
parle beaucoup d' esclavage aujourd'hui
en fait c'est une vieille histoire donc
à un moment attention c'est pas juste
l'industrie de la mode là aujourd'hui
nous sur le plateau en france qui devait
tout changer mais tous les pays
doivent prendre en compte leurs
travailleurs les respecter négocier et
ça vaut pour los angeles pour leicester
pour prat tour en italie également pour
aubervilliers max dormoy dacca il y en a
énormément donc c'est aussi toute une
coopération internationale et on voit
bien le monde on voit bien le globe tout
ce puzzle de législation c'est terrible
à l'homogénéité vous parliez d'
esclavage vous propose d'écouter
l'eurodéputé raphaël glucksmann c'était
devant le parlement européen à bruxelles
on est en décembre et
de l'an dernier à peu près un an et il
parle évidemment de l' esclavage des
ouigours la main d'oeuvre d'une partie
de l'industrie textile en chine j'accuse
les dirigeants du parti communiste
chinois du pire crime contre l'humanité
du xxième siècle la déportation et
l'éradication du peuple ouïghour
j'accuse j'accuse la communauté
internationale de consentir à ce crime
par son silence et sa passivité
j'accuse j'accuse les dirigeants de
nombreux pays musulman du pakistan à
l'arabie saoudite qui brandissent d'un
côté leur foi en étendard et de l'autre
soutiennent la politique chinoise de
destruction des mosquées et de
profanation des cimetières
j'accuse j'accuse les patrons cupide de
nike de zara et de tant d'autres
multinationales qui bénéficient de la
réduction en esclavage d'un peuple et la
justice française a ouvert une enquête
pour recel de crimes contre
l'humanité contre des géants du textile
uniqlo zara maje sandro ou skechers
est-ce qu'il ya dsk eu des actions de
boycott est ce que ça a eu des effets
sur le chiffre d'affaires de ses marques
je bien malin celui qui pourrait prédire
exactement pas citer les c'est compliqué
on sait pas exactement ce qui est
étrange si vous voulez dans le monde
compte et surtout pas sa on peut être
mais ça justement c'est ce qui est
étrange si vous voulez c'est que les
payeurs des comportements scandaleux de
grandes marques y sont dénoncés ils sont
rendus
public et ça a un impact très court
parce que rapidement passer à autre
chose c'est là où la logique de la mode
s'applique
élections ces vêtements c'est à dire que
on sort un scandale et puis un autre et
donc on oublie et on achète une paire de
telle ou telle marque et qui cite est là
parce que finalement on a je pense qu'il
ya aussi une question de presque de
dissonance cognitive hamster qu'en fait
on veut
répondre à des exigences de la société
les injonctions sociale d'être à la mode
et on se voile la face sur la réalité
sous-jacente ferrari vous avez décrite
quoi qu'il a effectivement gros un
esclavage pas tout proche mais pas si
loin et on veut continuer de rêver parce
que la mode ça fait rêver donc au csii
anne-cécile semble c'est ce que disait
audrey tout à leur dire on vit on fait
mal et c'est ça la vie c'est aussi se
faire plaisir effectivement je pense que
la façon de se faire plaisir et ce après
avoir entendu ces j'accuse
c'est tous les jours il ya eu des
pétitions sur instagram pour boycotter
ses marques c'est effectivement comme le
disait je ne sais plus j'ai oublié le
ton benjamin benjamin
ça s'éteint et ça tourne il ya ça dure
une semaine et puis après hop on passe à
autre chose et puis après on passe à
autre chose c'est comme la mode je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'on comprenne j'ai
l'impression que c'est un jeu de cartes
où il faudrait composent les cartes sur
la table qu'on dise où elle a laissé
problématique là ces problématiques et
voir ce qu'on peut faire au niveau des
dirigeants des gouvernements qu'on
arrête de taper sur le consommateur le
grand le consommateur lambda qui aussi
doit s éduquer on doit les ducs erreur
oui mais je rebondisse sur ce que ce que
le son qu'on a précédent qu'on a attendu
celui de stella mccartney quand elle
parle de génération x y z etc c'est
effectivement là on est dans une prise
de conscience beaucoup plus forte
catherine dorion alors la génération x
est la mienne c'est vraiment les anciens
les les vieux seigneur du lot moi je
dirais plutôt regarder ce que font les
millénium les millennials s'il défilent
tous les vendredis avec des pancartes
anti changement climatique et se
précipite sur vinton et et ses hlm donc
là il ya une espèce d'ambivalence une
ambiguïté énorme dans cette génération
la plus grande peine c'est un marché de
la seconde c'est une aberration et tais
toi ces secteurs ont fait une aberration
écologique déjà au niveau de la
pollution numérique évidemment quand on
constate des photos des photos des
photos et ben ça ok les trois
amériques ici effectivement
évidemment le passé les vêtements comme
ca ht pour les comptabilisant ceux des
emballages je devais césar allait pas
chez cette ambiguïté de la vente sur
vintage oui mais c'est toujours mieux
que de racheter un vêtement neuf quand
même nom mais chemin des gens qui
vendent effectivement aussi oui mais
quand même enfin je moi j'essaie de de
trouver des solutions médianes à ne pas
faire culpabiliser ceux qui avaient
moins c'est parce qu'elle est si on leur
dira non la seconde main c'est pas bien
non plus il ya des a par contre il ya
des entreprises de seconde main qui sont
des acteurs de la seconde main qui sont
vraiment extraordinaire c'est qu'il
fonctionne pas comme vintage justement
eux ils n'acceptent pas par exemple les
t-shirts à 2 euros il ya un minimum ils
sélectionnent leurs vêtements avec un
modèle économique avec un modèle
économique qui fonctionne oui et ça a
payé aussi cher au match voilà c'est le
seul chercher une alternative à
l'entraînement et hommage
hommage hommage au m aj que je vois là
on aura citer plein de marquer c'est le
principe quand on fait ses rangs des
jeunes il faut il faut sous très vite
les belles initiatives parce qu'elle
comme des gens qui ont les super truck
et audio sur la fast fashion c'est pas
bien ça c'est pas bien h m c'est pas
bien regardons ce qui se fait et moi
tous les jours je rencontre des jeunes
qui font qu'ils ont des super multi vas
bon exercice à tous je rappelle aux
ramiers le titre de votre livre le livre
noir de la mode aux éditions de perry
green et valérie tribe la base c'est au
cherche midi je vais